hey my name is Malcolm I'm a bartender
living in Los Angeles so I'm spending
today trying to figure out which of
these five people is actually drunk so
usually the number one thing you look
for out of somebody's like really drunk
eyes if they're glossed over that
probably be a good indication then pull
sleepy another thing would be how loud
they're talking because sometimes just
will be drunk you get louder you get
excited seeing if they repeat themselves
try to ask them maybe same question
twice to see what they get an answer are
you I'm good on your knees Malcolm my
job is it on another angel its angel God
I want to make sure all right angel
where you from I'm originally from the
Bronx bro I didn't live there for that
long so now I live in sunny Los Angeles
California video lake only five years
old months later I'm in south-central I
like it here but I'm moving in August
and that were you don't Hollywood nice
that's not too far for me I'm in Miracle
Mile okay see ya are you saying you're
gonna come over or what do you see I'm
definitely come trying to kick it I want
to be part of this group chat like
friends of you guys after this that's
the group chat where we talk about Matt
being like is he cute is he not we don't
know he's got like a real like adorable
puppy but I feel yeah where was the last
bar you before
last borrowin - it was probably like
West Hollywood all right angel thank you
I think I'm gonna take Matt on my cute
Juliet Oh Juliet where for art thou all
right sorry
I'm ready for the questionnaire all
right so Matt we're you know that were
you quarantined right now I thought you
were gonna ask me where I'm from I was
excited to tell you Malcolm
I'm sorry sorry sorry I'm in Chinatown
Los Angeles how long you been turned
around that's three years now where you
from in New York that dream tomato my
guy grew up in New York live there for a
bit then moved to New Jersey you know
the tri-state jump but yeah I live move
to fourth question 2016 right LA and
then I called my mom I said mama I made
it I'm in LA I'm in Sherman Oaks and as
I see an in-and-out burger I said mom
I've made it and she said she said lose
my number and go home for the holidays
you know I'm really I'm really something
all right Matt what what's your drink of
choice GM Peas GMT you should try that
compound sometime what is that
it's just Lennon a little bit of simple
syrup and gin topped off with soda
really good it's a good summer drink -
what though what are you training today
Oh Bailey's a little a little B Zeidler
Irish cream we're Irish that's
definitely not as intensive filming line
nobody dressed dreams
then coffee are you kidding me coffee
okay you just said just like damn Wow
well you asked me what the alcoholic
beverage was yeah I'm just sipping on
that cream straight out of the bowl like
my cat mm-hmm oh no we're binos all
right ready to go all right welcome
what's up mate
okay I feel part I think it's a waiver
that is a really hard question so I grew
up in Illinois outside Chicago and then
we're after Illinois then I went to
Washington then I moved to Milwaukee
then I moved to LA then I moved to
Philly then I moved back to Seattle then
I moved back to LA which was yes I went
to University of wisconsin-milwaukee
then I was Santa Monica College then I
went to Temple University and now I'm
doing online through Penn State I can't
say any one spot if you can't tell wait
so how are you like getting multiple
degrees is this all like what is in the
person you know I literally go to school
really a one semester and then like no
over and then all these schools are
undergrad degrees yes
yeah I just 321 I literally like
oh they are you know I'm skipping you
this is definitely not I'm not nonsense
why are we mad you show me an ID that
says you were 2100 you know you are you
serious I'll show you right now oh my
god I'm not gonna lose $30 oh my god
where's my wallet
put your hand over the cheque you just
won 50 bucks I'm recording on my phone
or else I defend it all right so wait
you just turned 21 so where did you go
when you turn to go out nowhere its
quarantine baby oh I just literally just
went whoa babies nice to meet you happy
birthday I'm so sorry that you celebrate
it's okay I love you so much thank you
for chatting all right let's go dude
same bag no rule number one don't tell
boys you love them when you're 21 next
video I'm gay oh sorry
do not tell grows you love them when
you're 21 either don't tell anybody
all right Irish what's going on up you
seem to be the cool calm collected one
of this crew definitely I'm Libra all
the way through man I just want to be
killed
all right what are you drinking today I
bought some real agonal right before
Lauren started so I just threw that in
with some orange juice and now we're
here where are you guys going to that
words actually I was gonna say Echo Park
man yeah I'm on Alvarado anyway I have
no clue what street I'm on it's not my
you got you got you yeah no I'm in Echo
Park like Filipino town where you from
originally
San Diego California [ __ ] baby there you
go your folks know that it yep
have you just have you seen her in
quarantine you've been sticking all time
my dad came up a couple weeks ago I'm
worried I don't know if I have it or not
and I know he still sees like my grandma
and grandpa's stuff so he we just kind
of talk to each other like in the street
it was weird as light was weird because
that's my dad and like we couldn't get
we couldn't get close all right I think
conversation just chillin you know
there's nobody like being mad at each
other like the other ones
I do seek Vantage I do speak Spanish
yeah so you can you think thank God I
Nina where are you from Canada oh okay
so I'm moving around like May above
primarily in Orange County
I've lived in essentia your Belinda and
I do just my grandma and one of my aunts
right now what is your dress okay so
they call me thick inna Karenina because
I love tequila
I like you watches me hashtag Latino
that no but like for real
okay so thick ela and but the thing is
because I ran out like a couple weeks
ago so I only know I was just a Trader
Joe's
yes right but I have a drum in my fridge
so I had to get over I have Tennessee
whiskey so I have that I'm drinking
whiskey we're waiting for you Beverly
Hills California whoa look at you
I'm Linden all right so I looked over my
notes I've thought a lot about this is
the first time I've ever had to decipher
if somebody was actually drunk or not
because usually a bar is help pretty
easily who is so I'm feeling like
there's three of you who really played
it up one of you kind of like plated
chill who still might not be trunk so
I'm gonna from first crossing off and
only this is probably the wrong because
she's an actress I gotta cut off this is
like she's just trying to be a role
you know compacted trying to do
something for real that was too chilled
and so I think he's not in either angel
is he's he's he's the he's the third
toughest but I'm gonna say it's not him
then it came down to me and Irish for me
and I feel like what happens we need
three you have like fun easy
conversations and the easiest fun
conversation I had was with Irish maybe
that's just cause he's a chiller
he's nope but I'm gonna guess it's
fittings a little tipsy and that's my
I wrote the drunk-person raced ok and
make yourself known
I know since I was the one I was worried
all right I should have done it was a
little tough picking it because I think
also knowing that four people were
faking it and then ultimately I just won
with Irish because you told a story
about his dad and feel like people
divulge details about that live Steven
they're a little drunk so I thought you
know what go with that one maybe I just
liked him the most and so I picked him
at the drunk guy
[Music]